when we look inside of eukaryotic cells
we see membrane-bound organelles and
some of these membrane-bound organelles
are particularly interesting for example
here is a diagram of a chloroplast that
are found in plant or algal cells
and we know that this is where the
photosynthesis takes place but what's
really interesting above and beyond that
is that it seems that chloroplasts have
a lot of the machinery necessary for
being a prokaryotic cell on its own we
don't see it acting on its own but it
has its own dna it has ribosomes which
we know are the site where we go from
messenger rna to protein
similarly another interesting
membrane-bound organelle that we see in
eukaryotic cells and this would include
even animal cells in the cells in your
and my bodies are mitochondria and
mitochondria are often viewed as the
energy factories of eukaryotic cells
where we can leverage oxygen in order to
produce atp and like chloroplasts
mitochondria has its own dna it also has
mitochondrial ribosomes here are some
just diagrams of how mitochondria might
look inside of a larger eukaryotic cell
and so evolutionary biologists for many
decades looked at this and said well why
do these things exist why do they almost
look like prokaryotic cells on their own
and there's even examples of prokaryotic
cells independent prokaryotic bacteria
that live in symbiosis inside of other
cells and they look an awful lot like
mitochondria and chloroplasts
and so if we fast forward to the 1960s
someone named lynn margulis comes on the
scene with
endosymbiosis theory and her view is is
that these membrane-bound organelles
like mitochondria and chloroplasts if we
go deep into our evolutionary past say
two and a half billion years ago their
ancestors were actually independent
prokaryotic organisms that could produce
energy aerobically or using oxygen and
precursors to what we would consider
today to be modern eukaryotic cells that
might have already had some
membrane-bound structures like a nucleus
and maybe some other things
that they
could only metabolize things
anaerobically they couldn't leverage
oxygen while these other characters
could level leverage oxygen and then
they could have become symbians where
the one that could leverage oxygen to
produce more energy would get engulfed
into the larger cell and that larger
cell is able to provide nutrients and
protection while the smaller cell that's
engulfed inside of it is able to better
metabolize the nutrients and leverage
oxygen to produce more energy and that
over time this symbiotic relationship
became even more connected so that the
smaller organism could not operate by
itself that it lost some of its dna that
was necessary to act independently and
some of it might have gotten
incorporated into the dna of the larger
cell and those smaller organisms are
what eventually evolved into what we
consider today to be mitochondria this
is a fascinating theory and it's
actually been proven out when lynne
margulis first published this in the
late 1960s she wasn't taken that
seriously but in the decades since it's
been validated as we've looked at the
dna structures of mitochondria and
chloroplasts that this actually is the
most likely theory of how they emerged
in our cells and so it's just a
fascinating glimpse of evolution in
general we talk a lot about natural
selection and the role of variation in
mutations but lynne margulis introduces
another idea that could catalyze
evolution and that's that of symbiosis
and we see symbiosis throughout the
natural world and her argument is
sometimes those symbians beca can become
so co-dependent on each other that they
merge into one organism